the argument that america is oppressive
and evil
to people with no forget race for a
second
forget even sex let's talk about sexual
identity
that is also ridiculous burger king just
tweeted out yesterday burger king
burger king tweets out quote they're
referring to their chicken sandwich
the chicken is chicken is their chicken
sandwich
says lgbtq plus rites
they don't says what they're just saying
it's like when kirsten gillibrand was
was filmed during her failed
presidential campaign
it was during a pride event she just
goes gay rights
i was like well what about them what are
you saying they say the same thing they
say
during pride month even on sundays
your chicken sandwich craving can do
good we are making a donation to hrc for
every chicken
sold this is a direct shot at
chick-fil-a
and through chick-fil-a this is a direct
shot at christians what they're saying
is
that they're going to donate to one of
the most evil
organizations in the entire country the
human rights campaign the human rights
campaign
is the this preposterously named
organization that existed
to get and founded by some very very
unsavory people who
have done very very creepy things uh
founded to redefine marriage
and they they succeeded at redefining
marriage they're the organization with
the equal sign
and because they succeeded at that but
they wanted to keep their money coming
in
they now have moved on to the
transgender issue which is ironic
because it seems to in many ways
undercut the homosexual rights issue
and now they're they want you to trans
your kids right so now
the hrc i mean truly a vile wicked
organization that should not exist in
this country
is getting money from your whopper on
pride month even on sundays
haha get it chick-fil-a is closed on
sundays because it's a christian company
but we're an anti-christian company
yeah we're so subversive we're so
subversive what are you talking about
that's the dominant culture
right now if you if you went out in the
dominant culture
and you espoused a modern secular
atheist liberal worldview
on anything on life on sex on rights on
government
do you think that would get you into
more trouble
than if you were a christian and you
went out and just expressed the
christian view of these things no of
course not
you could lose your job you could lose
your place in society you could lose
your reputation
if you espoused christian orthodoxy in
fact if you
want to maintain those sorts of things
your place in society your reputation
your job
very often you have to to some degree
implicitly or explicitly
go along with leftist orthodoxy
and it's very hard to keep up with that
orthodoxy in the spirit of pride month i
want you to know
i am i'm really proud i know pride goes
before destruction and a hottie spirit
before fall
i am proud though of this youtube
channel
and all you people who have subscribed
that's so great if you haven't
subscribed yet
ring the bell subscribe get the
notifications head on over also to the
audio podcast
at apple podcast google play spotify
stitcher i don't know where myspace
xango live journal subscribe there too
please leave a five-star review we'll
see you next time
[Music]
you